hi my name is Adam Koch illowsky with
IBM cloud and I'm here to talk to you
today about apache couchdb a database we
depend on extensively within the IBM
cloud and one that powers a lot of
innovative modern cloud native
applications the first thing you'll
notice about couchdb is the way it is
built of the web users make HTTP
requests to the database and the
database responds with JSON payloads and
developers tend to find this to be a
really natural fit in this era of
micro-services applications where all of
your apps functionality is is itself
being decomposed into these different
web services the other accordant
critical features about the database
though are you know under the covers so
to speak the database has a very durable
storage engine something that was built
from the ground up for this kind of
modern world of variable cloud
infrastructure it's a crash friendly
design that always knows how to pick
itself up back up and keep on living
it's also a very reliable system CouchDB
was developed in a programming language
called Erlang that hails from the
telecommunications industry and benefits
from its decades of experience running
production telephony switches and
finally couches a no sequel database
it's a non relational database and that
means that it makes some trade-offs you
have to think about how to model your
data in you know JSON document form and
you have to have a pretty good
understanding of the kind of queries you
want to make of the database so that you
can design the right you know views and
indexes to support those queries but if
you do in exchange for that you get
scalability you get predictable reliable
performance of the application as the
data volume grows and is the number of
users of your application increase but
really the killer feature about CouchDB
is its synchronization capabilities
let's say you started building your
cloud application over here in US West
and you have decided that you need to
add a disaster recovery site so you can
at any point in time replicate the data
from US west over here to u.s. East and
now you've got you know an always
up-to-date copy of the data over here in
this other cloud region but it doesn't
stop there you can also choose to set up
that replication in an active-active
bi-directional fashion now not only do
you have another site for fault
tolerance and high availability but you
also have the ability to direct your
users over on the east coast to the u.s.
East region for lower latency
but couch doesn't stop there in fact you
can include any number of different
other databases in different locations
into a single replication mesh you could
have on-premises systems you could have
you know edge locations you could have
databases running in other cloud
providers and each of those is able to
take you know possibly a filtered subset
of the data down from one of these
regions and make changes to it and push
it back up all right that kind of
flexibility is really you know without
peer in in this world of cloud databases
and I think it's something that is
particularly valuable in this hybrid
cloud multi cloud world in which we live
today thanks for watching this video if
you have any questions or comments drop
us a line if you enjoyed this content
please Like us or subscribe